Endosteal eskies book,
Crime and punishment.
He has his main character.
[inaudible] cove decides that he's going
to commit a murder and he has very good
justification for the murder.
And Dostoevsky is very good at this.
He,
he puts his characters into very,
very difficult moral situations and
gives them full justification for
pursuing the,
the,
pursuing the pathway that they're
pursuing.
And so [inaudible] cove,
he's broke and starving.
He wants to go to law school.
His sister's about to prostitute herself
rough,
roughly speaking by marrying a guy that
hates her,
that she hates and that,
and he has contempt for her,
at least acts in that manner.
He's trying to rescue his mother as
well,
who's also in dire financial straits.
He,
he,
he goes to a pawnbroker to pawn his
meager position so that he can continue
to scrape by.
And she has this nice,
uh,
I believe it's her niece that's not very
bright,
who she basically treats us as a slave
in his horrible too.
And,
and so the care,
the pawn broker has this money risk.
All Niqab is in dire need.
He thinks,
look,
I'll just killer because why the hell
not?
I'll take her money.
She's not doing any good with it
anyways.
I'll free or niece who's just working as
a slave.
She's got all these other people tangled
up in her pawnbroker schemes.
All that will happen is the world will
be a better place and the only thing
that's holding me back is conventional.
Moral cowardice and Dostoevsky has his
character in crime and punishment go
through days,
hours,
hours and days and weeks of intense
imagination about this rationalization,
about this,
trying to justify himself,
placing a metal outside,
placing him self outside the law so that
he can perpetrate this act and telling
him self with all the best nihilistic
arguments that the only possible thing
that could be holding them back is an
arbitrary sense of indoctrinated
morality and so dusty Esky explorers
that he does commit the murder and then
of course all hell breaks loose because
things don't necessarily turn out the
way that you want.
He gets away with it.
However,
while he gets away with a technically
because no one knows he did it,
but he doesn't get away with it in
relationship to his own conscience and
so that the rest of the book explores
that well,
Dostoevsky,
I believe it was in crime and
punishment,
although he makes the same point in many
of his books.
He makes a very fundamental point and
this is the kind of point that that I
think that people who haven't
investigated these matters down this
particularly particular literary and
philosophical pathway,
never grappled with Dostoevsky,
said straightforwardly if there's no
god,
so if there's no higher value,
let's say if there's no transcendent
value,
then you can do whatever you want and
that's the question that he's
investigating.
You see,
this is why I have such frustration say
with people like Sam Harris,
this sort of radical atheists because
they seem to think that once human
beings abandoned their,
their grounding in the transcendent,
that the,
the plausible way forward is with a kind
of purest rationality that automatically
attributes to other people equivalent
value.
It's like I just don't understand that.
If they believe that that's the rational
pathway,
what the hell is irrational about me
getting exactly what I want from every
one of you whenever I wanted at every
possible second,
why is that are irrational and how
possibly is that more irrational than us
cooperating so we can both have a good
time of it.
I don't understand that.
I mean it's as if the psychopathic
tendency is irrational.
There's nothing irrational about it.
It's pure naked self interest.
How is that irrational?
I don't understand that.
Where?
Where's the pathway from rationality to
to an egalitarianism virtue.
Why the hell not every man for himself
and the devil take the hindmost?
It's a perfectly coherent philosophy and
is actually one that you can institute
in the world with a fair bit of material
success if you want to do it so I don't
see.
To me,
I think that that the universe that
people like Dorkins and Harris inhabit
is so intensely conditioned by
mythological presuppositions that they
take for granted.
The ethic that emerges out of that as if
it's just a given,
a rational given,
and this of course precisely niches,
observation as well as Dostoyevsky's.
That's Nietzsche's observation.
You don't get it.
The ethic that you think is normative is
a consequence of its of its of its
nesting inside this tremendously lengthy
history,
much of which was expressed in
mythological formulation.
You wipe that out.
You don't get to keep all the
presuppositions and just assume that
they're rationally axiomatic there.
The rational to make a rational
argument,
you have to start with an initial
proposition.
While the proposition that underlies
western culture is that there's a
transcendent morality.
Now you can say,
that's a transcendent morality
instantiated in the figure of God.
That's fine.
You can even call that a personification
of the morality if you want to,
if you.
If you don't want to move into a
metaphysical space.
I'm not arguing for the existence of
God.
I'm arguing that the ethic that drives
our culture is predicated on the idea of
God and that you can't just take that
idea away and expect the thing to remain
intact midair without any foundational
support.